I like him all right for those who are like every for the chat who are just like trying to adjust the audio right now we're all gonna be using in-game voice chat later yeah I'm not going to bounce it too heavily yeah yeah yeah just to make sure resurrected recall your base by pressing please just adjusting the foggy stuff right now there's like little dead frogs on the ground wait can I grass for help it's to help you the fuck is the foggy shit oh I like your food you know okay oh yeah thank you yeah it's cute yeah does it animate because sometimes it doesn't oh nice sometimes it doesn't work oh there you are I was like where the I mean she's kind of like perpetually animating but that's fine too all right crying yeah I actually when I was in like china that there was like a tack uh the taxis or the ubers or they're called dd's they would have like the tvs at the back and then they're they're always playing the chicawa shorts and i thought there was like substance to chicawa shorts but
it's literally like have any of you guys watched the chicawa shorts substance what do you mean like okay the first short i saw from it is really like the bunny mix a giant pizza and then the p then then she shares it with chikawa and then the short ends like where is the substance where like it was like that was like four minutes too
yeah it's about friendship doki
and like demons wait what what explain yeah you have to watch oh do i have to have do it's like every episode is a filler until like episode 13 where like a demon shows up and kills chikawa's mom and now you're all on a mission to avenge him place item hold on i'm making a frog spear oh yeah that it was so buggy for me when i was doing that fireball took me so long to piece that together fireball oh press one
someone was not reading the instructions i cast fireball did you see the accent menu where it's like yo if you're british fuck you wait really it did say that on the main menu click accent menu you got american or indian and that's it why is it american or abian wait there's only two accents in the world american and indian freeze yeah they said the british version wasn't working for anyone so they disabled it it was too hard to understand what oh yeah yeah for some reason it wouldn't it was so hard for them to register whole i kept i was like whole Hole.
Hole.
It actually worked all the first time for me except for freeze.
Everything worked except for hole.
Yes!
It's like, oh.
Okay, it worked, it worked, it worked.
It worked.
Hole.
I'm happy for you.
We did it, guys.
We learned how to say hole.
Magic missile.
Nice.
Okay, I may exit the tutorial.
How do I get out?
Oh, you just need to be me, Mew.
And then join my lobby.
He told you, dude.
Use your escape muscle.
Yeah.
Oh, my escape muscle.
Join my lobby, guys.
We are alive, I think, so, you know, don't dox yourself, Snuffy.
Yeah, all of...
I mean, she's live, too.
Also, I think Snuffy had all of us turned down to zero.
I have Snuffy turned down to zero.
no she isn't talking on zero but she didn't light up so she can't hear it yeah yeah i don't think she realized that all of us are at zero but we're going to turn all of us down to zero anyway in the end she doesn't know she lacks critical information does she know does she know does she know i'm gonna join your walk everybody hi did you did you have us at zero i was watching you guys just bounce up and down for a little bit yeah yeah we all did that we all did that it's okay we'll turn all of us for this game what yeah it's yeah because it's uh it's also a uh in-game vc oh right we have a lobby code don't we okay yeah let me let me leave i've been waiting for you guys leak it leak it yeah actually don't leak it we don't want anyone saying slurs.
They'd never.
I was looking at the Steam reviews and they're, yeah, no, I was looking at the Steam reviews and they were like, yeah, people are saying slurs now.
No.
Oh, no.
Which mode are we doing, by the way?
Oh, I mean, there's only, there's only one.
Well, there's two modes.
One's a 1v1 and the other's team.
So I'm pretty sure we're...
It's kind of like a death match, apparently.
Yeah, but death match is a 1v1.
Oh, it's...
yeah so um so we're doing the normal we do we'll do medium uh we'll do medium size first because i don't know how big it actually is are we supposed to hear each other right now on the long no no no okay i can recapture the game right i don't have all right we're all in we're all in yeah i'm generating the world okay okay and now we join i'm wait i want to be a wizard i'm a sorcerer Stop!
Stop!
You want to say anything?
Okay, Doki, guess we're on each other's team!
Yay!
You want to say anything to Stuffy, Bid?
Stuffy, it's not you.
I just wanted to be on a team with Live, but now you're gonna win.
Not you!
i think i can i could win with anybody no no i've got i've got the weird hybrid accent i'm gonna confuse the shit out of the game it's gonna be awful you know one minute i was it didn't work one minute i was both in the vc and we were waiting for you two i was like oh it's okay snuffy's not doing a tutorial yet you don't have to do the tutorial and then mid was like no i don't want
like we're two wrong directions we need to like hold somebody else's thing snuffy you we we are copy barra people we're not the gamer people we can't have a repeat it's okay we'll just we'll just switch up teams every round yeah yeah yeah yeah stuffy over it's not you snuffy it's not
for my whimsy it's okay it's okay okay so apparently you can uh change our maps so we can edit our map and everything wait if i draw on our map mint do you see me drawing on our map you can draw on the team flag that oh no oh wait i see it yeah i see that why did you pick like shit green oh jesus okay wait i don't want to erase that oh we can't erase We have to re-true it.
We have to physically...
No, you can, you can, you can.
You're erasing it right now.
Yeah, no, I have to use the white brush.
Okay, what are you drawing?
Oh, one's bigger than the other, sorry.
Oh my god!
What did you do?
What is this supposed to be, David?
What is this supposed to be?
What did you do?
What did you...
Oh, wait, we can make them sand under tape.
What did I do?
We're gonna be sad.
Fire bulbs on the flag, I'm sorry.
Oh, Snuffy, you're making such a beautiful flag, thank you.
Wait, hold on, I'm gonna get a reference.
I'm gonna get a reference.
I'm drawing, okay, this is gonna be, you get it?
It's Limon, right?
What the fuck is Limon?
What?
You don't know Limon?
Limon is my mascot.
Oh, Limon.
I'm trying to, I'm parsing it right now.
I totally, I see the vision.
I see the vision.
I kind of forget what he looks like a little bit.
I think he has a very pretty bad name.
I don't think he's got any blue on him, but let's go.
That's my, okay, that's where I come in.
Wait, fuck, that was too big.
All right, all right.
This is him.
It sounds like you guys have a good thing going.
Stop erasing it.
Oh no, we, we, we, I immediately drew a dick.
that kind of upset about it okay and that's just not very wizardry i know i think this is good we got our flag down yeah we got ours wait we could save it to disc honestly snuffy's putting so much effort into this all right you save our flag i did okay our flag's good to go you're not gonna expect this yeah yeah yeah leman's base color is white if That helps,
Sophie.
I was hoping for, like, a light cream, but there wasn't...
Yeah, no, you made him piss.
He's, like, piss, man, now.
Piss, man.
He's, like, lemon lemon.
It's okay.
I believe in us, man.
I...
I believe.
I can say whole.
Yeah, I can also say whole.
Let's select the magic word Hool.
Hool.
Oh, man.
All right.
Are y'all ready?
I'll start the game.
Okay, I'm going to lower everyone's volumes.
Okay, I'm lowering everybody's volumes right now.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye-bye.
All right.
It's time.
Hello.
Okay.
Oh, there.
Is our flag up there?
Is that our flag?
wait it's just white no i forgot to save the is the flag white for you i forgot to save it it's just a white flag you keep oh for you you forgot to save it yeah i thought because you saved it that i would see it oh no i'm wait let me push i'm gonna up the volume for the voice real fast
Really?
Okay.
Is it better now?
No, yours is fine from my end.
Is it better now or no?
Yeah, yeah, yours is much better.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
So you press escape, you can like, like adjust the audio on the top left for like other people.
And it loaded in!
I see it!
I see sends!
You see sense Wait, I don't hear you.
Oh, I said lowered you all the way down Okay, I hear you now.
I can hear you now.
Okay.
Whoa Fireball what did you do?
Oh shit, I'm by myself now.
Oh Wait, that's not what I expected.
I thought you'd respond.
I'm so sorry I thought you would respond I didn't know I thought you'd come back I didn't I so mad how do I how do I get her back guys respawn respawn how do I bring her back I didn't realize I thought she'd come back I thought she'd respawn it's okay it's okay everything will be okay everything everything will be okay maybe maybe you I didn't realize she doesn't respawn I didn't know I thought she'd come back oh no wait you're right let me close the gates oh no okay maybe if i find where they live first before they find where i live first everything will be fine okay it's fine everything will be fine how do i open my map okay it's cute okay where do i live oh oh she's back i see it minfan told me she's alive wait oh my god she's alive the warlocks have captured the mushroom biome where do you have wait we haven't done anything wait we haven't done anything yet okay she's alive i didn't fuck up guys all right sound guy is are any of my sound people here okay guys she's alive i didn't
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, nice.
We did it.
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm okay.
All right.
We got the Amish Hill, guys.
We did it.
I did it.
We're doing so well.
I believe it does.
Okay.
We're okay.
We're split up.
See, I killed her.
So we can split up faster.
that was the plan and it worked guys it worked because look I got us the flag look at that yay
I got us the frog bog guys I did it
oh my god how do I how do I get out of here okay I'm doing it I got us the frog bog See?
Everything is fine.
Is that you?
Mitt?
Oh, there they are!
Fireball!
Oh, wait, that's you, Mitt, sir!
Mitt Fireball!
Fireball!
Oh, oh!
fireball oh shit fireball freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze no no no no no I fireball you live fireball fireball give me more fireball oh oh my god freeze freeze Freeze!
Freeze!
Fireball!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Oh god.
Fireball.
Okay, I just have to say it more calmly.
Fireball!
I cast fireball!
I...
Freeze!
Oh my god.
Fireball!
Please, where's mid?
Fire!
Fireball!
Freeze!
Oh god.
Where's... Magic Missile?
magic missile magic okay fireball fireball oh my god your back your back mint fireball fireball fireball okay I'm going back to get frog island you got this mint I'm going back for frog bog island I believe in her I'm claiming bug.
I remember how to get to bug.
Wait, where's the flag?
Wait, maybe I don't remember.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, no!
Wait, she died?
Oh, my God, no!
I was trying to find the flag!
Oh, my God, the gold back i have to go back okay oh my god i'm stuck oh i have to go back oh she's gonna claim the land i thought she'll live wait where's my oh no oh no i have to go back okay fireball okay that was just me experimenting freeze oh shit
Fireball!
magic missile!
Oh my god, we're in by!
Magic missile!
fireplace!
fireball!
Fireball!
Oh shit, fireball!
Oh my god, how did you say it's so calm?
magic missile?
No!
Oh my god, it's the accent!
I don't know where Snuffy went.
What do you mean she doesn't know where Snuffy went?
Fireball!
Wait.
What the fuck is going on?
Why are they making wormhole?
There's no base!
I can't respond because there's no more bases to respond in.
Oh no.
The game doesn't understand.
Also, how's the sound?
I don't know where my sound team is.
Are any of my mods online?
I'm actually scared.
Oh my god.
Oh, I have to create a new lobby.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I was looking.
Oh, Discord.
Wait, why are you guys messaging on...
I'm there.
Uh.
Wait, we're missing.
We're missing, um.
Alright, let me look up.
Sound thing.
You bring sound down, but the overall...
Wait, what sound?
What?
Bring what sound?
Bring.
Bring down what sound?
Mons.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, just the effects?
Well, I can't do that now.
Wait, where is...
No, no, you click...
No, you click...
Play it again, and we all in the same lobby.
Now I got confused.
But I'll give her the...
Thing in.
all right okay sound effects down and overall up all right we just gotta wait for that okay nice all right so I might have messed up and killed mint a bit too many times it's okay I believe in snuffy and me we can do this all right we What the fuck is a splutterer?
Wait, are they like...
Basically, guys, we have everybody muted in just...
I believe in us.
We don't have a flag.
We...
Okay.
can...
do it.
...
Oh shit, wait, you're right.
You're right.
I have an idea.
I don't think Snuffy knows that we're drawing the flag right now.
You're right.
I have an idea.
Okay.
Is that what raccoons look like?
I don't remember.
And then...
Shit.
I'm like, watch you again.
Safety
disc, start game.
Magic missile, magic missile.
Fireball, fireball, fireball.
Freeze!
Magic missile!
Fireball!
That's right, run!
Run, you fuck your raccoon!
Run!
Okay, let me just let me close our thing Okay, let me make sure our volume has I can't, I can't, uh, my sound team, I can't turn down sound effects.
This is the highest I can do.
All right, all right, truce, truce.
We have to work together, stuffy.
We have, truce.
We have to, we have to work together to beat one live move.
Okay, okay, we can take her down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we can do this.
We're moving to our demise right now.
Okay, wait, I need to fix our volume.
him real quick okay okay okay so when men and I oh my oh you were crafting okay what does that you got the ramble but what can I do with that I don't know I just pressed it I did this oh it's
All right, well.
Oh, that's awkward.
Hooray!
We got our base!
Okay, sound team.
Just talk in the chat.
In the chat.
It's easier for me.
Okay, I'll put everybody up.
Alright.
But I turned down the overall volume.
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
We can do this, I believe.
Alright.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's, it's fine.
We can work together.
It's, it was an accident.
It was a workplace accident.
Accidents happen.
Fireball.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I have this.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
What are you doing there?
What the fuck?
Fireball, fireball, fireball.
Fireball, breathe.
Freeze!
You fucking!
How did you do?
Fire, magic missiles!
Magic missiles!
Good job, man.
Good job.
I know, it's kind of OP.
I know, it's just, watch the...
It's so severe!
my god what did she make oh my god what the fuck was that oh my god wait is this ours do we claim this already i don't know oh yeah we did we claimed it is that what teamwork is how is teamwork magic missiles
Okay, we can do this.
Oh my god.
Fuck is the flag.
I don't know where the flags are.
I'm gonna slowly head to their base.
They'll never know.
Wait, isn't that our base?
I'm gonna slowly...
Whoa, whoa.
Where am I?
Whoa.
what the happened to me okay i don't oh that's that's that's my house i think the warlocks have captured the sorcerer's base oh no no no little tunny no oh my gosh she did it stuffy did it so i'm doing it
It's okay.
What is this to say?
Lab M plus L.
Wait, what?
Why is it not capturing?
Hello?
Give me our base.
There you go.
Oh my god!
Matchy missile!
Magic missile!
Fireball!
Freeze!
Yes!
Fireball!
No!
Yes!
Okay.
Okay, we did it.
I'm a hero.
Oh, fireball!
Fireball!
Freeze!
Oh my god.
Magic missile!
Fireball!
It's okay.
Freeze!
Magic missile!
Magic!
Oh!
Magic missile!
Fireball!
Oh my god, I don't know if it's working.
I don't know.
Magic missile!
That's not you!
Oh shit!
Fireball!
Yes!
You hurt yourself!
Magic missile!
Oh, I know your- I see you!
I see- Freeze!
Freeze!
Fireball!
Our spells are only grows stronger magic missile oh shit magic missile magic missile magic missile fireball freeze oh my god oh my god freeze magic missile oh sorry fireball cast fireball i cast fireball fireball fireball Paul made a fire!
Magic missile!
Oh shit!
No!
It's so close!
Ah!
I did the best I could It's not It's Lymo, she's like three of us We should do it Make it 1v3 Us Us versus Lymo
Us Us versus Lymo This is the only way This is the only way for us to win.
Also, sound team.
Is everything better now?
I lowered everything.
If all of us work together, we can win this.
It has to be all of us together on a team.
also oh where's lime lime will work lime will where are you where is lime will where did she go oh oh the game crashed i was like where did lime will go see lime will the castle I'm okay This is the only way it's actually the only way to defeat her It's like I can't believe the game doesn't register my voice like doesn't register my accent I'm literally speaking with an American accent.
How much more American does the game want from me?
Oh, yeah, a rare live one thing it's discrimination it's discrimination against me and only me hi i'm like i was like the only one that was unmuted and everyone was just like a stream of consciousness and it was like yeah i didn't think anybody else was unmuting wait are you guys unmuting?
but since your game crashed i was like okay we should yeah are they talking to us either they just talk no while we're just talking I'm gonna leave the lobby I like how snuffy is still having us muted me in there or something so I will have to remake it I think at Doki unmute yeah I already unmuted you're unmuted yeah I was already I was listening to you guys I thought if you guys were yapping and stuff yeah exactly
okay Am I making a new lobby?
Yeah, please.
It says the lobby's full when I try and join now.
All right, I'll make a new lobby.
All right, it's three.
Okay, we're 3V1ing LIMO.
Like, this is not 3V1 LIMO.
This is the only way.
It's literally the only way.
Don't leak the code.
Leaking the code.
All right.
Sorry, friends.
You can't join.
All right.
We just need Yeah, all right, I make I start Lobby Alright, Labu Get away from us Get away I got everybody I'm muting everybody Wait, but we have to make our flag Oh Wait, I'm muting Libu only You're gonna make flying I'm wearing No,
I'm gonna listen No, I'm gonna listen to everybody Alright, alright, here you go Oh wait, who do I join?
Oh, warlocks The warlocks Alright, let's make our flags guys let's make our flags all right what is making this i'm not drawing okay who is the purple and who is the gray but i want to be like kill live move kill i don't think right kill live
I'm going to draw a knife with blood on it.
Yeah, I'll add the blood.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, there you go.
Save to disk.
flag if she even changes and I don't even know what she would be just the smiling thing oh no all right are you guys ready to start game we glow we have like red glowing eyes I don't know if Lamu's done with her her flag though but I'm gonna start I'm starting the game guys okay okay okay I won't kill it
Anybody this time.
I won't I won't kill my old teammates.
I promise
Also, can you guys up your volume real quick for your mics?
Yeah, yeah for your like in-game like for the you go settings and then do like volume.
Could you up that a bit for me?
Yeah, it goes settings and then you go push it all the way up I did it All right, Snuffy could you also do that too?
What did you make?
Okay.
What is that?
Well, what does it do?
Okay, so what did you make?
What did you make when you fucking like firmly grasped Snuffy and I?
How do you make that?
Okay, what the fuck did you make a walk-in stick?
That's it.
That's all it does I don't know wait, it makes you jump it makes you jump Oh, oh, it's a pogo stick
Yeah What does it do Yeah
oh my god oh my god is there fall damage is there fall damage no no no there's no okay okay that's good that's good oh he follows us look at him oh he's like our little pet okay we get i'm gonna close our okay we're gonna we have to walk together guys let's walk
Someone should pretend.
Um...
I'll pretend to defend.
You're your defend?
All right.
I believe in you, Shum.
You got this.
Oh, Chad told me something crazy.
Wait, does it work?
What?
What did he...
What did you do?
Oh!
Wait, you already knew that?
Oh, I did not know that.
I just saw her went super saiyan.
Oh.
Oh, oh, wait, the mushroom biome.
That is, that is like too hard, right?
That's over here, over here.
That's the mushroom biome.
Where I'm going.
She's over here.
Okay.
Oh my god, mince fucking bouncing.
Wait.
I got the flag.
Okay.
Yeah
Oh my god, I just hear a boom boom boom boom boom boom boom.
By the way, Lamas was actually on the on the other direction I fucked up a little but they don't know that They don't know I messed up Oh, I'll go to back home Wait, there's a dead guy here.
Hello?
My face Excalibur is lost Excalibur?
No, not Excalibur.
Oh no!
My wounds are grievous.
Oh, are you gonna die?
Wait, I heard Minx saying Vibe.
Oh shit.
Sorry, I got help.
The worm got you!
Fireball!
The worm here!
Magic missiles!
Fireball!
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
Magic missile!
Wait.
Wait, where is she?
Fireball!
Oh shit!
Magic missile!
Freeze!
Oh shit!
Midplace!
Freeze!
Magic missile!
Oh nice!
Fireball!
She did, she took me, she won me, dude us.
How is the VC recognizing her and not us?
I don't understand.
Why is the VC recognizing her point?
Okay, speak calmly.
Speak calmly.
Oh, hey, there's little men here.
Hello, little men.
Greetings.
Fireball.
I'm mad.
Oh wait, she was gonna trade me.
Oh shit.
I- whoops.
That was my bad.
I didn't realize it said trade.
Wait, that's my spell book.
Wait.
Okay, I have- I have rock.
what does rock do wait what does rock do i i only have one spell and it's a rock i didn't know it's a stupid this is my
it's a sad face i Did it!
Okay, I gotta open this.
I'm very slowly opening the portacoulis.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
Okay, that's mine.
Okay.
Oh, what was that?
What was that?
That was so scary.
What the fuck was that?
It rose from the ground.
worry.
I have my one spell.
Oh, I think Min and Snuffy are like fighting her right now.
Oh my god.
Oh my legs.
Where am I?
Oh, it's right here.
Oh my god.
Lyme killed both of them again.
Life is actually...
Oh, fuck you, I want you to be doing all of us.
It's okay.
I've claimed another land for us.
I claimed that...
Oh, no, not our base.
I'm trying to figure out how to get out of this fucked mushroom world.
Okay, we got this.
All right, I'm heading over.
I think Min's trying to fight Limo.
Oh my, I got Limo and...
Oh!
What's that?
Was that me accidentally using my other magic?
It's okay, I got...
I'm doing the objective.
I don't know what that was.
I think I actually said rock.
God, this is so hard to claim.
Yay!
Okay.
I just got dropped down.
Okay, now I know what that does.
It's okay.
I have this spell.
It can only grow stronger.
I can save us.
Rock!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Stuffy, please.
Rock!
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
It's fine.
Rock!
It's weird.
I got you.
I
got you!
I got you!
Rock!
I don't have rock anymore.
Thank you, my fucking god.
I don't have rock.
That's all I needed.
It's okay.
I don't have rock anymore.
Wait.
Is he?
We did it!
We did it guys!
Guys, it's okay, we did it though!
Wait, what?
It's really hard to know who is who.
Once I figure out sorcerers and the difference between wizards and sorcerers, it's easy.
I'm like, I can't tell if that's wrong.
Okay, what's...
Okay, what does it The hope is that...
The game does not recognize my accent at all.
And...
He's so like normally.
Wait, what's... Do you guys want to do with the large map?
Fire...
Wait, does that...
Wait, it actually made a fireball?
Wait, did it make a fireball?
Fireball.
I want to play again.
We're still playing the game.
All right, I'm going to click play again, guys.
Okay, we'll do a large map.
Large map.
We have, I'm lackey, sputterer.
Uh, can I please pee?
No.
I guess.
I get it.
you really need to
okay lime apparently crash again
all right lime apparently yet she keeps cracker she crashes whenever she tries to play again and because of like we have to remake oh wait no she's back all right i'll start it in edit team flag
everyone oh wait i'm fine with this i'm fine with this
what if we just explore the map as friends oh i actually press start i actually press start I
Okay, I was gonna say
Okay, we got a we all didn't even join a team though no no I actually press I actually press play So No, no, no.
She's not in the lobby.
She's not in the game because if you press escape, fireball.
Okay, we got to kill each other.
Magic missiles.
Oh, okay.
I, well...
Can I have one kill?
No.
Magic missile.
Oh wait, I can't kill myself with that.
Fireball.
Okay.
If I just stand...
Fire...
Fireball.
Okay, fireball.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I figured it out.
I figured out the tone.
That, okay.
We have to leave the lobby, I think.
our game is never ending because we we have our base okay i'm gonna leave game wait i'll leave game until when they leave game because they're still here i'm gonna practice fireball Okay.
I'm practicing.
Magic missile.
Freeze.
Fireball.
I did it.
Oh, wait.
Stums in.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Oh, she did load in.
Fireball.
Okay, I had to- I was just testing.
I-
Okay, it worked out.
It worked out.
Everything worked out.
All right.
Oh, Snuffy's by herself.
Let's explore!
Hello?
Wait, Snuffy loaded in?
She loaded in?
Yeah.
Yeah, but come here.
wait what's that what did you do to me did you give me what did you do to me what did you do what what did you what did you do what did you do to me
did you get me cooties freeze
freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze worm wait wait okay no no truce truce guys we work together we were oh no I fucking fell truce truce let's explore together let's explore together and be a happy family oh
oh oh Please, Sophie!
Please, let's work together!
We can be friends!
Fireball!
Fireball.
Wait, you killed yourself.
Wait, wait, that's a bad...
Wait, who's that?
Freeze.
Wait, who the fuck is that?
Who's that?
Oh my god.
I don't know who that was.
Freeze.
What the...
Fireball.
Like, who is that?
Their warlocks have captured the crystal caverns.
Yeah.
What the fuck was that?
That was not...
Yeah.
That was an NPC right there.
Wait, Snowfie never even claimed her flag.
Stupid.
That's right.
That's what she gets.
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
Now she has no home.
I wanted a truce.
Please don't hurt me, please.
Don't kill me, please.
Oh.
Now you want truce now?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I tried to get a truce before.
Oh, you want a truce now?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you want truce?
Or you want to die?
Do you want a truce or you want to die?
I heard those words before.
From a wizard.
An enemy wizard.
Fireball!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, oh shit, do that!
Hello?
Mint?
Mint, we're on the same team!
I can't believe you would just say fireball like that.
Fireball!
Oh!
Where am I?
That's it.
That's how you get.
That's fucking it.
Where is she?
Fireball.
Oh wait, fireball.
Please!
Okay, cheers.
yeah freeze worm hole that
was just chilling back in the face right now I was I think she she thought snuffy never made it back it's like she hasn't moved since.
Limo?
Yeah.
Limo hasn't moved at all.
No, I didn't see her kill anybody.
No, she was here.
She was?
Why isn't she moving?
Oh, Limo can't respond because we never claimed our base.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We might have fucked up there.
she's been apparently she's been like watching us wait what's that a little guy fireball we did it
the timing is that that's the thing
I think I think a snobby kill there's not the moment we fucking just killed a child I'm gonna click I was so good Sorry let me tell us like What happened?
How did we win?
I'm gonna click I'm gonna click play again
Look at that I know I was like we killed a child Okay everyone Truce Truce Let's explore the great wizarding world to get it.
Apparently, there's secret stuff around the map.
That child deserved it.
all right start okay actually we'll do large start lobby okay we truce guys truce we are a team now all right we are a team but i would like to be on lamu's team even if we're trusing if we're true okay let's make my flag.
Wait.
Peace.
Actually, this should be red.
There you go.
And then there's a heart.
Alright.
Okay.
Hello?
Okay, we will work together as in I will make sure I don't teen kill.
See I don't have the focus.
Wait really?
Wait what?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was perpetually being hit by spirits.
It was some bullshit.
Oh my god.
Wait, what did I make?
I got the...
Oh, I got a blade!
Yeah, front blade.
I think it's for stabbing.
Oh my god, I can shank people!
Wait, what's... Yeah, we can shank!
Look!
I thought she had more HP.
I... Wait, what?
Uh-oh.
Oh Wait, I'm fucked up.
I can hear their comms.
I'm like
Wait, I can hear them.
I can hear them.
Is it because of the sins I've committed?
I why do I hear them as if like they're ghosts?
Wait, where did Lamu go?
She disappeared.
Why did she...
Why am I hearing the voices?
Where did...
Where did Lamu go?
Why is she floating out of the...
Why is she floating out of the map?
Where did she go?
Oh no.
I didn't mean to.
I thought she'd live.
Hello?
Peace?
Do you come in peace?
Come in peace?
Peace?
Yes, I am peaceful.
Why did you murder Lymu then?
Because... Because...
Look, no, no, no, no, this is the peace blade.
This is the... This is the peace blade!
I swear to God!
Okay, it's okay.
It's only for...
It's only it's for our own safety.
Did you make me smaller?
Did you make me?
I can still
I can still shake your ankles, you know that right?
I can still cut your ankles
Right, don't make it...
That's right, don't make me do this!
I've got to shake your ankles!
Is this what she did?
Is this a... is this...
It's the right way!
wait what i'm gonna shake you i'm gonna shake you
i'm gonna get what's this Now I have the walking stick too.
My peace play.
What does that say?
Anyway.
Peace.
Is that also peace?
I come in peace.
Do you actually?
Yeah.
I thought we were supposed to explore.
Yeah, we are.
Am I still tiny?
back to normal height oh wait okay here here's your walking stick thank you but where's snuffy then why do you have that what's my peace blade okay a common peace she's in the middle wait where's snuffy on your map in the middle okay oh wait then they're both together let's go to the middle then okay Yeah,
yeah, we gotta explore.
There's the door.
What the fuck do you mean?
Yeah, I stab in peace.
Stab in peace.
You don't stab at all.
I stab in peace.
Hello?
Come in peace.
We wanted to explore the crystals.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, let's go!
Let's go explore!
In here, in here.
Oh!
There's one right here too.
Let's jump down.
They're peaceful shankings.
Oh, we can like have fireworks!
Fireball!
Let's go, I leave a portal here like the- Like- Oh yeah!
And then, we'll have multiple portals, just in case.
Worm.
And then, we jump down.
Oh.
Didn't seem like it.
Oh, put it...
Put up.
Okay, and then I'm gonna make a hole.
Oh.
Wait, a hole.
Is that my hole?
Hole.
Oh, no.
I got the hole.
Wait, where are you guys?
I'm in the hole, too.
What's over here?
The Ravidonks have captured the crystal cavern.
I feel like there's nothing, yeah.
It doesn't seem like there's anything here.
What, but we gotta find a scalabry.
Wait, wait, we can all, like, try...
What?
Why did she just go through the hole?
Where did she go?
Oh!
Our hole expired.
No!
It's not a hole!
It's like, we can just climb up.
Yeah, it's kind of.
Oh wait, no, we can recall with B.
I think that's what she did.
Yeah, no, that's what she did, but...
Oh, she...
Alright, goodbye, I guess.
We're back.
Wait, what are you making now?
I don't know.
make I made a regular stick it's a grass walking stick yeah all right wait where did you find Excalibur it's in the trail you know the spooky place with the oh yeah yeah yeah so like what like did you were able to get Excalibur yeah I got it and then a bunch of skeletons glitched out and I couldn't see where they were kill them together wait we're okay i don't know where the other two are though maybe they went in here because that is where excalibur is so oh yeah he's walking around who i assume will attack us no we seem like nice people with our glowing red eyes it's on the other side of this place i think mint guys are you guys here we're in the spooky scary skeletons Oh god,
is she on the mountain again?
Oh, they're climbing Mount Everest!
Are you guys okay?
You don't have your Sherpa with you!
Oh, shit.
Oh!
Yeah, frog just ate her.
That's unfortunate.
Where's your stuff?
Wait, where's your stuff?
No!
Wait, what happened to me?
No, my stabby!
What happened to me?
I wanted to steal Lamo's stuff.
I got greedy.
I got so greedy.
No!
Oh my god, my legs.
I'm okay.
See, I'm so healthy.
What do I mean?
Give me an ingredient, and I'll make you a powerful magical soup.
What kind of ingredient does he want?
I don't understand.
What do you want, little guy?
Frogman?
No, I lost my pea stick.
My pea sword.
I lost it.
Hey little guy.
What is he doing?
Yep.
Fireball.
Boy, you got your crystal.
Is this what you want?
What is this?
What do I...
What do I have?
Okay, everyone's died in the fucking swamp.
He was just a little guy.
There's no such thing as little guys in wars.
Fireball.
Hello?
Oh hey!
What happened to the others?
Uh, Lymo's in there exploring.
I think she- Do you want to go help her?
Yeah, what's this?
Have you tried the soup before?
Oh, what is that?
Oh, what
is that?
Fireball?
Do you still have your sword?
No.
My peace sword got eaten.
By the frog.
Yeah.
I saw a goblin.
Oh, really?
Oh.
It's okay.
I drank a magic potion.
So I should be really strong now.
Okay.
What does a magic potion do?
Go in there.
I'll fight him.
Alright.
I'm ready.
With my torch.
Okay, let's go.
How do we go in?
I believe in Doki.
Alright.
Whoa.
Let's go in.
Okay.
Fireball.
Oh, I hurt myself in confusion.
I hurt myself.
I'm okay.
Oh, my God.
She didn't live.
She did not live.
Oh.
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, fireball.
Fireball.
Okay, I killed myself.
Holy shit, that area is so loud.
That episode, that area is so fucking loud.
It's okay, we did our best.
We're still alive.
yeah the explosions were so fucking crunchy I wish like the audio there were more audio settings instead of volume what
what said that
stuffy is that you stuffy is that you hello turn around turn around is that you there you are okay wait why do you sound like you're a ghost
like I just I felt like a ghost I was just trying to like figure stuff out and then everyone was like yeah I thought Pokemon Sun and Moon was pretty mid I was like who the fuck said that someone hacked into the lobby like yeah I'm about to say
We're trying to get Excalibur in the crypt, but we keep dying.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me see how you get there.
There's Excalibur in all the pieces.
It's over there in front of me.
I was trying to find things I could trade to the goblins for more spells.
Oh, yeah.
No, I gave him my spell book and my stick, and they gave me rock.
Oh, wait.
Fireball.
What are you trying to do?
Did he actually give me anything?
They look like they could, like, drop loot or something.
Wait, is that...
Yeah, if you kill the little goblins, they drop, like, little crystals.
Hey, guys!
Wait, where are you, Mint?
Hi.
We're trying to...
We're trying to find items to trade to the goblins.
I mean, I can give him my torch.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
There's, like, a ton of crystals by your place.
Oh, yeah, and, you know, I killed a bunch of kids near me.
Oh, are you supposed to kill the kids?
Yeah, you're supposed to kill the children and and rob them I think that was still in that the mausoleum.
Yeah
Oh my god.
Are you here?
I'm in here.
You're right.
Oh my god, I fixed it Oh, you got it?
Yeah, I got it What spell is it?
No, it does.
Divine light.
Whoa!
Oh
my god, all I had to do was do that.
Whoops, sorry sound guy.
I fucked up.
Okay, sound guy, now you can actually balance the game for me, for real.
Wait, what else is here?
I also got stuck in this room going around and around.
Oops.
Oh wait.
How do I break this?
Oh, easy.
You just do this.
You pull out your buff, and then you go fire.
Wait, why am I burning?
Wait, why am I...
Why am I burning?
Did you burn me?
Okay, let's go make Excalibur.
I don't think so.
How did I get burnt?
Okay.
Oh my god, wait, it does work like that.
Hey, you burst.
I literally all I have to do wait watch this.
Oh
Burn the witch
All right Yay
the blade I'm so wait stop drop and roll how do I stop drop and roll I'm gonna die wait wait wait wait wait wait I'm actually gonna die Wait, that would be divine light.
Oh.
Hello?
Stop it.
You crying.
Hi, Snuffy.
Snuffy, which base are you going to?
Because I'll come with you.
Do we have to craft it?
Yeah, I would think...
Okay.
Is there like a wild crafting bench you can use?
You can just use our base.
Just press B and teleport back.
I think I'm on a different base.
I will walk and escort you to my house.
Okay.
Let's go.
Maybe we'll bump into the children.
Sorry if it's like kind of messy.
We haven't cleaned up, you know.
Yay
Not punished I'm not a pyromaniac I swear Rock Okay, let me put this on here Rock soup Now put the other part on there Whoa Whoa Oh!
Can I murder someone in the name of science?
I know I'm an amen.
Oh my god, how do I get back?
Everyone's so far.
It's not that good.
We go this way.
Okay, I Don't understand what did I do
I don't
Okay, so guy did the thing let me know if it's better
Yeah, I I'm here.
I respond from it.
I came to hell.
Wait.
Hello.
Wait, did you drink the potion?
I could hear you from all the...
Even if I'm small, it doesn't stop me from burning people.
Get over here.
Like...
It didn't it like crunched down and just swatted me with her sword It does that what she did did she fucking swat me
Shrinking her
Absolute karma Did you fucking swat me with your sword?
20 rocks Huh?
What the fuck?
She still got me on fire!
I just...
Okay, it's not at half far.
I was really trying to grab a rock.
I just...
Put two rocks together.
Big rock.
I got more rocks.
Yeah, it's the rock suit.
They had...
What's up?
Hello?
Yeah, that's what you sound like.
That's when you were like...
You were tallying about how Pokemon Sun and Moon was pretty mid.
But on purple it has something similar.
You're not free of you wanting me.
Snuffy managed to find a spell that cost like wisps that tracked me through the entire fucking.
And Doki found a spell that made rocks like explode and then killed herself with it.
Yeah, I...
Yeah, that sounds about right.
That sounds, yeah.
Wait, wait, no, let's go to the Goblin Village and trade rocks.
There we go.
Let's go to the Goblin Village.
Wait, Lai-Mu, can I?
Okay, can I suffer off you?
yeah just take my divine light afterwards oh no actually I don't want it here what oh my god what that's what it looks like I got the grass I got the thumb thrombing stone divine light wait how do I use this divine light say divine light divine light Divine light.
Divine light.
Oh!
Blessed.
I feel so blessed.
I have this drumming thing, but I don't know what this does.
Where do the goblins move?
That's what, uh, Snuffy's been using.
What does it do?
I'm trying- Use it, use it.
Oh wait.
Hello?
I used it.
What did it do?
I don't think it works.
I think it's for the rock soup.
I think if you shrink me and I do rock soup, I just...
I think that's what it does.
What?
Look at it twitching.
You see it twitching?
No, I think it's only on your screen.
Wait, what if we're both tiny?
But let me shrink you.
What?
all right let's go let's let's go to the i won't go to let's go to the goblin village hey okay that's fine too
i want a scalper wait i want no can i I'll trade you!
Where did I
go?
Oh my god, I'm so far.
Where do the goblins live?
Where are the trades?
I don't know where the goblin village is.
Where the fuck is the goblin village?
Okay, I'm gonna claim this real quick though.
just in case oh they got Kilimanjaro
okay we got the forest here okay but where do the goblins live in the goblin village which one it looks like the goblin village I can't tell hello hey wait why are you guys so small we've been smalling each other okay now okay let's go to the goblin village and grab more spells Okay.
Yeah.
Follow the sound of the children.
You're...
The children luring me into the magical forest.
Apparently it's like all the bottom.
I think it's the bottom one.
That's where the...
That's the goblin village.
I think.
Let's go find them.
It's the...
He needs Nord.
it's at the bottom so it should be the right side yeah this way yeah yeah it should be no wait that's the swamp oh this is a tree i thought it was that's the swamp wait does this map not oh my god i can't see anything now wait we're wait i don't think we have the goblin village on this map have it this time yeah yeah i tried to tell you guys i didn't find it down here i think it is it north did anybody see north why does it say the rock golem and mushroom man follow you wherever you go on the map what yeah i did that i can do that too mushroom man i crafted the mushroom man before a mushroom oh yeah stew is a powerful way to use extra resources the spore frog how do we frogs we can make cooler things wait use the smite use the sword but don't get eaten on what on the frog freeze wait but don't get eaten help me out help me out you'll make the frog over here wait you guys got it how do we safely take care of no don't do that i don't want to run up with an excalibur eaten by a frog would
be pretty iconic Can you imagine he eats Excalibur and just like combusts from inside?
Guys, Min's been stuck in the swamp.
She's being quicksand.
Slon live.
The king.
I'm not regaining stamina.
I think maybe here.
Right here.
If you get out here, there's a slope here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let me try that.
Are you sinking?
Wait, there's the frog right there.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
Guys.
Oh, no.
Guys, now I'm stuck.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Oh, I got...
I did it.
Oh, the frog disappeared.
You gotta find a frog so we can...
Divine Light.
Yay!
Oh!
I hear one.
Yeah, we're killing a frog.
Oh shoot.
Oh, she didn't make it.
It's been unforgiving, isn't it?
Yeah.
And it dropped a toad.
Yeah, yeah, we need that for crafting.
I can't even get around.
There's a slope behind you.
You can bring it back up there.
I got rock.
I got the toad in my grasp first.
Wait, kill a toad.
Fireball.
that's definitely dead right is it no he's talking to us fireball fireball i got it do we just keep going i got a frog it spawns a frog where they died oh my god who is there a fireball i killed him i killed my frog oh my god oh i did not kill my frog he's looking at me guys the fro fireball we're just a bunch of wizards like exterminating the whole spot that's right they get what they deserve fireball fireball
why was it B why was it B I don't know why was it B I don't know how did dead what did i do rock down and then okay overall all right let me know that helps sound guy i can't believe why me what did i do wrong i've been so nice
wait where
I hear them.
Hello?
I think you gotta parkour it.
Wait, where are you?
Or are you guys going to the lava island?
Yeah, I think this is the last one I can explore.
Oh, watch out.
Other than the gob...
I think we have to reset the map to get goblin island.
Oh, why am I...
Why am I slipping?
Oh, why am I slipping?
Oh, why am I...
You have parkour.
Oh, it's a evil mage.
Oh, shit.
She's evil.
There's so many...
Wait, where's your smite?
Just smite them.
Smite them.
Fireball.
Oh.
I think Mint's dead.
Yeah, she did.
Oh, she gave you the smite sword.
That's why.
Oh, that makes a lot more sense.
Why did she die?
There's gotta be something cool here if they were protecting it, right?
Yeah.
Divine light.
Wait, where?
Where are you?
What does this say?
Wait, where are you, lad?
I went up a spiral staircase.
Oh, what the spell did you get?
Do you want to do something?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
you can't burn it.
You can't burn it.
Ah, that's me!
Divine light.
She killed me.
Why?
Why did she kill me?
Oh, my God.
Oh no, fireball.
Ow.
Oh no, lava hot.
Lava hot.
Lava so hot.
Hello?
Hey.
I'm back.
Wait, what spell did you get?
Thunderbolt, but we have to take it outside to use it because it doesn't work indoors.
Oh.
the only thing in here for now yeah maybe one of the other towers has more maybe oh my god i get up here there's towers yeah yeah there's different towers spiral staircases yeah yeah here's another one oh another spell what's in that one uh i don't know come touch it i'm running out of space Okay,
I'll look- I'll loot it.
Blink.
He could- Oh, fuck!
Where are you guys?
Um...
Uh...
Let's get out of here.
It sucks here.
And I think- Okay.
I- I- Oh, by God, I'm so unlucky.
Oh, let's get out.
Fireball!
Where did I die?
I don't even know where I died!
Where did my items go?
Oh, hey.
What the fuck is this?
That says Weed of the Pike?
What the fuck?
Am I just high?
Oh my Hello?
Are you guys alive?
Got fucking special beam cannon or something.
Where are you guys?
I'm inside of the Bowser's castle.
You're at Bowser's castle?
I have...
Oh.
Watch look at this wait.
Oh, that's you.
Oh my god.
I thought you were an evil person Wait, I used it all up.
What the fuck did I wait, no Wait, did you grasp did you just stole my item?
It makes you to slip poor item.
Did you just stole my weed of the pipe?
Oh, I didn't take your weed of the pipe I have my big sounding rod what the fuck happened to my weed of the pipe?
Oh, hey, oh, it resets itself Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait
The castle res- The castles reset itself That's cool Yeah, yeah, yeah You should come outside Wait, wait, wait, give me a sec I'm double checking this area Yeah, it resets itself We're new spells Yeah, I got another Weed up Wait, are you guys all outside now?
Yeah heading out who's that awkward dark blast fucker
whisp whisp that's cool oh that's interesting
wait Oh my god Oh my god What happened to me?
What the fuck happened to me?
You took my what what killed me?
Hello?
Oh my god, it's so oh my god, it's so with spell I kept you took my pipe You took it.
Whisp.
That's fuck you, right?
That's right.
Fireball.
Thunderbolt.
Freeze.
Magic missile.
Blast magic missiles Why is it a 2v1?
Wait, wait, wait.
I've been coming.
Where is she?
Wait, what does
this say?
The what is the black thing one?
Oh, I don't know.
You'll have to figure that out, I guess.
Thunderbolt.
Back blast.
Wait, but how?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Blink.
Nice.
That's right.
Whisp.
Fireball.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
We're not supposed to be a team!
Oh, hey, what's up?
I'm back.
Hey, what happened to be a team what happens oh we got some really cool spells and we wanted to see what they did why we have so many crystals i don't know combine it with a frog wait the fry also where did all these frogs come from well we killed like a million of them so i'm assuming that's where yeah but how why are they here wait i want to eat frog soup what's frog soup i ate that before it makes you get like a really weird tongue and you like smack people with it wait really yeah how do you smack people of it i don't like that oh you stole my fucking spell book that's what it does it makes you drop your item oh wait that's silly that's pretty silly i i guess it's like one time use yeah can i put these together ah that would have been so nice yeah
let me see what my items i dropped
wait where did all my dropped items go i died here i didn't take them yeah but like there were so many yeah where did it go then i literally died here did you die right there yeah uh i don't know where did i die There's nothing not gonna respawn because they were on the other team.
No, no, they were...
They were...
Oh, there's my stuff.
Wait, no, that's...
Oh, my stuffy spot.
That's all the frog stuff.
Yeah, my stuffy spot.
I just heard your tongue again.
That was weird.
I don't like that.
Okay, wait.
What can I do with...
Wait, wait.
Can you combine a crystal with a rock?
Yeah, that's all I was trying to do.
Yeah.
Wait, what does this do?
Wait, I can levitate?
Oh, yeah, you can lift people with it.
Mint and I did that first round, so she was just holding people still and I was hitting them.
Oh, that's what this does.
Thunderbolt.
Put me in the fucking lava, bitch.
I didn't actually do it.
That's what I'm assuming that I was going to put you in the lava.
Oh yeah, you'd never do that.
It was just a silly joke.
It was just a hee-he-haha.
I can't believe you in it.
I assumed such a thing that I would do.
I don't know.
I think that's pretty messed up that you instantly think I was going to do that to you.
It definitely was not rooted in prior experiences and I should have had more faith.
Exactly.
Wait, so what does this do?
We're all going to stick.
Don't you do it.
What does it do?
Oh, God.
You stab with it.
Wait, really?
Oops.
I just assume I steal her shit!
Okay,
wait.
I'm just gonna go super saiyan real quick.
So I think actually what it does is it sucks things out of people's hands because I dropped the sword when we did that.
Wait, did I?
Really?
Wait, how does that work?
Wait, can I try?
yeah oh it's like the soup
give me my thunderbolt back
i gotta leave the house i gotta leave or she'll know i gotta leave where she'll tp back I got it.
Yeah.
Oh, well.
Oh, no.
She knows exactly where I am.
She's chasing me.
She knows exactly where I'm going.
She's right behind me, doesn't she?
Can't catch me.
I just keep, I'm in the mushroom.
She can't get me.
Fireball.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
that's right can't catch me don't don't don't because I think I fucked up
close the door I know what to do magic missile
fireball what did you do
Fireball Oh shit Magic missile I'm dying the lava You'll never get the sword You'll never get the sword That's right
Little does she know Little does she know
Little does she know What?
Wait, what happened?
No.
It's okay.
Now no one can get hurt anymore.
Now no one will ever get hurt.
Wait, which tower did I go through this one?
Wait, maybe I I just went the wrong tower.
You're right.
Oh!
Fireball!
Oh,
Joe!
Oh, Joe!
I saw you on that map!
I knew you were here!
I saw you on the map!
Oh my god.
Magic missile.
I'll jump!
I'll do it!
Okay.
You'll never get the sword!
Fireball.
If I died, I'm going to swamp!
Ow.
Okay.
She won't find my body.
Maybe she won't find my body.
Maybe she won't.
Fireball.
She'll never find my body.
She'll never know.
What do you mean we'll never know?
Wait, where are you guys?
You'll never know.
Wait, give me a second.
I'm trying to get the sword back.
We'll be right back.
What do you mean the sword?
I'm trying to get the sword back.
I don't think she knows where I died.
Guys did she get the sword?
Oh.
Where are you?
Wait, I'm here.
What is that?
Let me use it on you.
Wait, what is that?
What did you do?
That does...
I know what that does.
You fucking...
That's
how I got the sword the first time.
That's when you get back here.
Get back here.
Are you bullying Mint again?
No, I'm not!
She's bullying me!
She was...
She was fucking...
Where'd she drop it?
I don't know where it is.
Oh, that's a tree.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, what is that?
Wait, can I try that?
Wait, can't I try that?
It's so cool.
Why am I purple?
Oh, I'm backwards.
Why am I backwards?
I hate that.
I see.
That's why you were purple.
No, she spit the thing at us.
She spit the thing at us.
No, she started it.
She started it.
I swear.
What the fuck is it on me?
I swear!
I swear to God!
A wizard should know to trust his stares rather than steal.
She- she's shot!
She's shot it!
And she said it!
I swear to God!
No!
Wait!
Ah!
It was self-defense!
I swear to God!
I was just defending myself.
At least let me have a balloon and fly.
What happened?
Wee.
Where
am I going?
Fireball.
If I keep dying up, nobody can hurt me.
Fireball Oh my god
It's a meteor Fireball Fireball Fireball Nice, nice, what are you doing?
The air defense is crazy Little do they know?
Keep this forever.
The antire.
What the fuck was that antire?
Wait, how the hell is this way?
Firebomb, it says calmly.
Hello, I'm back, everybody.
Wait, so how do you guys make the floating balloon?
I wonder what else there is in the biomes Kind of seems like all the loot we probably can get I mean we could we could We can Wait how did you make that anyway It's mince I got it from her body Yeah but how did they make that Like the balloon and the poison thing Okay so I found out I
see her like A divine message from the gods That she desires the frogs I want to bring frogs to me
which which one is our house or like their house sorry is it this way it's the on the other side wait so how did you guys make that
where did you get a balloon
where did you get a balloon Wait, what the...
I just wanted to know!
I still...
Instructions unclear!
Wait, can I kill this child?
Oh my god.
Nobody saw.
If there's no witnesses, did it actually happen?
if you think about it if a tree falls down in the forest and nobody was there to see it didn't really happen goblins will passively bring me see them coming behind me holy fuck they'll just passively bring you all these items yeah so while you capture it they'll just keep taking you frogs and rocks so that's how you get in the tears I guess wait so I'm going to leave wait ow this Yeah,
this guy keeps fucking throwing stuff at me.
He's a bad boy.
No, he's not.
He's my child.
He's a bad boy.
He's a bad child.
Ow!
Oh my god.
No more children in the workplace.
No, no, my child, please.
Let me have him.
Please.
I'm gonna go put him into the ocean.
Yeah, yeah, kill the child.
Don't kill the child.
You want to reroll the maps for the, uh, Yeah, yeah, I want to try it in the morning, so I can't do much more.
Wait, how the fuck?
I want to know what this is.
It's a blue dart, right?
Yeah, but how do we...
How do we...
Is that the one with the frog?
The combine?
Rock, like, rubbing against rock.
Can't combine it with anything.
Hmm.
I love when I can hear the text on the text.
Alright, you guys want to re-roll the maps and see if we get the Goblin Village?
Yeah, yeah.
Follow me, okay.
Okay, okay.
But before I re-roll it.
Oh, they just explode.
Oh, the children explode after they give you stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah, you've been killing them.
But they're useful.
No, yeah, but when you kill them, they still drop the stuff regardless.
Look at my chat.
So you watch this.
Wait, what?
Alright, let's reset the map.
Oh my god.
I'm resetting the map.
The new lobby.
I made the new lobby.
Alright, large.
We did it.
This is why.
What did I do?
I don't know what I did wrong.
I don't know.
I don't understand.
What did I do wrong?
I thought I was a good person.
I thought I was a good person throughout that run.
There's a magic mirror on the wall?
Mirror mirror on the wall.
Okay.
What's this?
Wait, what is she trying to draw?
I can't tell.
Is that supposed to be me?
Is that Homer Simpson?
Homer?
Simpson.
looks like a prince
and then what's that is that tongue what is she what is she drawing
and then that's the belly button
That's, those are the nipples.
Why did she color the nipples?
All right, we're good to go.
Why did you color the nipples?
Alright, let's find the goblin.
Oh, wait, wait.
What did we get?
Apparently there's a magic mirror somewhere.
Yeah, right here.
He's on the wall.
Mirror mirror.
Whoa.
What does he say?
Mirror mirror on the wall.
Who's the fairest of them all?
Magic mirror?
Mirror mirror.
Who's the fairest of them all?
Who's...
of them all just goes oh oh that's all he does mirror he just goes oh my ass kind of hurt all right I got the important weapon all right mirror mirror show me the fairest of them all oh it's a yes or no question oh it's it's a yes or no question all right magic eight ball yeah it's a magic eight ball uh you think raccoons are evil mirror mirror is dokey bird a filthy little freak get out of here get out of here get out of here get get away from the mirror mirror mirror mirror mirror on the wall it's snuffy a piece of shit raccoon
mirror in this household i'm having it i'm putting i'm putting frog and whatever what is that for frog what does that do Wait, you just gave me smoke.
Oh, I guess it's just a smoke bomb.
Yeah, I think that's really...
Mirror, mirror, mirror on the wall.
Our raccoons are evil.
Oh, he said yes!
He said yes!
Vital to the environment.
She said no?
Mirror, mirror, on the wall.
Our raccoons, trash pandas.
yeah okay is do raccoons serve no purpose oh i said no to you
hey guys we're using the mirror yeah yeah yeah the village didn't spawn so we were oh did the village spawn no i didn't how do you know there's like so many things we can see them so we got the dead on the maris the swamp mount everest the fire the top Oh,
that's the...
Oh, that's the...
Oh, okay, we'll do it again then.
We'll spawn it again.
Okay.
Do you like our flag?
Huh?
Wait, why are you guys...
Why are you guys...
Get off of our flag.
Get out!
Get out of my...
What the fuck?
Mage playground.
Let's go.
Get off of our flag!
Fireball.
The trails of little fire sparks.
Oh my god, no.
Everybody be nice.
I did it.
I'm trying to get our thing back.
I'm trying to claim our lands back.
Fireball.
Oh shit!
The evil chick bug cloud.
So much violence so quickly.
Yeah.
All right, I'll make the new lobby.
Okay.
Wait, does the village spawn in large or medium?
Or only medium?
Guys, do villages spawn in medium in large maps?
Because I know the village showed up in medium.
I only put large because I wanted to have like a more likely chance to spawn in.
Yeah, but you know, there's a forest spawn in the- okay, I'm gonna do large.
All right, I'll do large just in case.
Okay, we were figuring this out.
Okay.
All right, what is Snuffy trying to draw this time?
What is this?
I don't know what she's trying to draw.
Oh, it's a pony!
And then the cutie mark is...
It's a...
The cutie mark is basically...
Um...
That's the cutie mark.
I'm gonna give her a torch!
It's like my beautiful face and our beautiful flag.
Do nothing but live my life.
It's called.
I got an orb.
Wait, what's that?
Ponder the orb.
Wait, what does the orb do?
Wait, the forest!
See through the eyes of the enemy.
Wait, what?
Oh, so you know where they are.
Yeah, here, wait, look at it.
Look at it.
Wait, okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
All right.
Oh, look at it.
Oh!
Oh, they're looking at their spells.
They're outside their house right now.
Okay, we should journey and see if we can find the goblin camp.
Alright.
I think the goblin camp...
Wait, we have to grab items to trade with the goblins.
Oh, true, right?
I got some items in my hand.
I think the goblin camp is in the middle.
Okay.
Oh, frogs.
Oh, I think the... Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, they're crafting right now.
Okay, I feel like it's a sit- should we go through the swabs then?
We just go on the edges.
Yeah, the edges of the swap.
Oh.
Okay.
Duffy's fucking wild.
She's wild for that.
Wait, that has to be the forest.
Oh, here, here.
I found it.
Here they are.
Let's trade.
Hello, fellow wizards and sorcerers.
Yeah, he takes books.
Last time I accidentally gave him my book.
He traded your book for one crystal.
Congratulations.
He traded me a log for a log.
Wait, he got me a rock?
Gave me a log?
Oh He gave me a magic spell I got it told Why are you praying me for your mistakes?
Divine light What?
Wait, I got one called rock That was my spell Yeah, that one was the one I have one But I'm gonna cast it over here because it sounds scary Oh, I got a spell blink blink what a spell what the fuck oh yeah that's how we killed Doki with last round she likes that spell you should show it to her which one it's the rock wood it has a very long cooldown though say it again oh rock oh if you stand on top of it you can go high up oh that's crazy is it No,
it's show- it's like flies up.
Oh, wait, that's fucked up.
I think it only does it whenever it's like- That's fucked up, bro.
That's pretty fucked up.
Maybe she'll get her book back on- Snuffy, can you check- can you check if you can trigger it by saying Biden Blast, please?
Okay.
Okay, that's pretty good.
Blink.
Woo.
I don't like the blink one.
I'm trading that.
Wait, you got a blink one?
That's cool.
Wait, he traded me the blink spell back.
They don't like re-gifting, bro.
I got weed of the pipe.
Leave me alone.
Whatever you got.
Oh, okay.
Divine light.
Why did this guy have such dark stars?
Why does the game hate you so much?
What does Divine light do?
It heals.
Hi, welcome back.
Welcome back.
Sorry, I thought you were joking.
I tried to blow her up with the laser beam.
Yeah, and I was like so far away.
Rock Rock
Divine light Divine light Divine light Wisp.
Divine light.
Divine.
Okay, there we go.
Whisp.
Did you do it?
It went down at the end, so it said, Whisp.
Rock.
Whisp.
I have divine light.
I have divine.
There you go.
Whisp.
I think this one's my favorite spell.
You want us to try it maybe it wasn't we can't we can't finish the stream until you see you get the whisp off come on Whisp whisp Wait, let's try let's try and see if it works Wait, I think we killed oh my god.
We killed we killed half the town.
Oh my god.
You killed them all We accidentally killed half the town guys Wait, you're like an Anakin Skywalker.
Can you say it like a scientist's speech?
Wait, you killed the last goblin!
You killed the last...
Why is it 80 so much?
You killed the last one!
Whisp.
Oh, shit.
What is it?
Order 63 or something?
Rock.
Whisp.
Divine light.
Blast
Okay, give it to us.
Let's see if we could do it Try it.
Let's try it.
Let's try it Whisp Whisp Whisp.
I think you have a I think they gave you a done spell.
Should I try it?
Whisp Whisp
Whisp Whisp Whisp Whisp Okay, okay, I can't do it Someone else do it
Whisp Your turn Whisp Okay, so it's just me and Mint It was It was me and Mint Can you try more on the S&P?
Whisp.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Wait, how do you do it?
What are you focused on?
You try?
Whisp.
Rock.
.
Wait, can I try?
Yeah, it's still, it's still a little, I guess.
It's like whip cream.
Whisp.
Oh, oh, you have to do it fast.
What the fuck does this spell even do?
I don't know.
It's like a very small amount of damage to your enemies or something.
Divine Light.
Maybe if you're trying to find someone.
Rock.
Wee!
Divine Light.
Oh, wait.
Divine light.
I tried to snipe off.
Whisp.
Oh, it slows you down a little too.
Handing spells gives me such power.
I really do think.
Yeah.
I think my favorite is Biden Blast.
Oh my god, no.
Wait, can I try the Biden Blast?
I haven't done it in real life, but I remember when I was a kid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I want to try Biden Blast.
Come on in Dragon Ball.
would like run around the playground shouting attack names and stuff and acting out with the body so i yeah yeah
i i kind of saw that coming i really should have not given you that i don't know i don't have it i don't know where to talk to me i just have rock
divine light oh divine light yay I don't know what that does other than make me feel good.
Okay.
I, I didn't know it one shots because when you use it on people, they didn't die.
They definitely died.
No, they didn't die instantly.
They didn't die instantly.
I thought I thought it would have been, I thought it was like a two shot.
I thought it was a two shot.
I swear to God, I thought it was a two shot.
We got, we got to get rid of the evidence.
We got to get rid of the evidence.
Gotta get rid of the evidence.
No, we gotta.
We gotta get rid of it.
Other things are...
Our words with blast in it.
Come blast.
Fireball.
Oh!
The firelight!
No!
Very good.
Wait, I want my stuff back.
Oh my god.
I can't believe they synced it.
Oh, that was crazy.
Oh, Shepar, I was in the swallow area.
I can't believe they synced that up.
We were trying to get rid of the evidence.
God.
I can't believe.
Oh my god.
When you're panicking, it doesn't work.
Okay, I need to press B.
I can't get out of the swamp.
It's too, gosh darn dark.
Oh, I don't have my torch anymore because I traded it away.
That's crazy that that's how it works.
The village is in front of me?
Yeah.
Hi, Ducky.
Hey.
I didn't know.
I didn't know it would one shot.
I swear to God.
I didn't know.
Snuffy and now we try to recover you guys.
We're Snuffy.
Wait, did Snuffy die in this in the trees?
I don't know.
She's over there.
She's in the mushroom kingdom.
Snuffy?
Oh, Snuffy TP'd back.
I thought the nobes don't come back.
That's kind of fucked.
Wait, where did Mint go?
Mint got your orb and decided to go and see if she could do things with it.
Oh, it was just a pondering orb.
Like, literally just...
You could see whatever where, like, the other eyes are, like, looking at.
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah, it was just a pondering orb.
I don't have a...
torch anymore because I traded it to the goblins and then we killed all of them.
So, um, I don't think I'm getting a torch back.
Oh.
Hey, I hear somebody.
Snuffy?
Oh, Mint?
Wait, they're back, you guys.
You lied to me.
Wait, that was my boy.
What's that?
Oh, they did come back.
They're here.
Oh, they did!
Nice.
Dark Blast.
Oh my god, you killed!
You killed the guy!
What did he do to you?
Doki doesn't even want to trade anymore because you killed his friend!
Wait, Doki, did you ponder the orb?
Yeah, I pondered the orb.
You can basically like stream snipe the enemy.
Yeah, it's crazy!
Yeah.
I mean, I could just pull up your stream instead, but like, yeah, it's pretty...
Well, I mean, that takes a lot of effort, actually.
This.
What did you do?
That was the whisp.
Oh, that was the whisp.
Whisp.
Do we want to call it here?
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I want to do one last trade.
One last spell trade.
They won't give me anything but damn frogs.
They just give me like mushrooms.
I wish we did not kill the majority of these people.
I didn't blast.
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
I have to go back here.
This way.
See?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Guys, it was not I just turned in a beam a little bit too long.
Hello.
Hey, Min's killing the wall No No, I wanted to get rock Mint I'll bite you He's like muted her I wanted to get rock Why are you so close?
I'm so sad I was so sad they'll come back in the nighttime they sleep i'm so sad i wanted to get rock what about rock though
what are we all like living the same day every day i was about to end it No,
why don't we, how about we all, how about we all get in a, got, all get tight in the circle together and we all just fireball each other, like fireball into the center together.
Right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
New idea.
We should be like a skewer, two dark blasts on the end simultaneous just like, oh my god, wait, that's, that's a good one.
The skewers.
Wait, what?
The Biden blast skewers.
I have one.
And then it's a Biden blast skewer.
Yeah, that's fine.
Apparently you say come blast, it also works too.
What works?
Yeah, stuffy tested that up.
Or like brain blast?
It's gotta reload.
Okay.
I'll count us down when you say you're ready.
I'm ready.
On one.
Three, two, one.
Biden blast.
Holy shit.
Oh, hey.
We got blasted.
That was so good, dude.
We just flipping Biden blasted.
We all just evaporated into the air.
Wow, what a way to go.
Can we drown?
I know, I feel like- I'm thinking we're playing it more competitively.
You can.
I'm returning to the sea, goodbye.
Alright.
Wait, you can die from the ocean?
My people need me.
Wait, I think we're dead, dead for- oh, wait, no.
Alright.
I'll TP back It's called drown
Oh, they left Hello, I am muted the game.
Oh, yeah, no stuffy and I we again would be really funny.
We went and drowned You oh yeah, yeah, we went to the ocean together and just drowned ourselves Yeah, that sounds that sounds beautiful mint and I we just said goodbye like normal people Yeah, we had passion in our depths.
Oh, okay.
We had a shore.
What do you mean, shore?
We're just Vikings.
Yeah, we have a Viking funeral.
There's cotton there.
That was fun.
That was fun exploring everything.
That was really, really fun.
Thank you for inviting me.
Yeah, who's going to give you more updates to it?
I hope it updates more.
Yeah.
Listen, shit.
emotes i want emotes oh yeah emotes more spells yeah more spells would be really cool yeah i saw that it was developed by one guy oh really yeah like um a horse a broomstick a spell drive by you just wrote right up on your horse and just go fireball and then ride away you could do that with the frog balloon Oh my god.
That's so true.
Just fine.
Okay, that was okay.
The anti-air shit of all three of you guys were shooting fireballs and freezes at me in the sky.
That shit was crazy.
I saw you guys in the distance and I thought you were like just having fun and like trying to like like in my eyes when I saw you.
I saw Goki like flying in the air and you guys shooting off fireballs.
I was like, oh my god, look, they're trying to shoot off fireworks for Doki.
Oh my god.
And then I get closer and they're just like dying.
And then he said, he joined in and was like, freeze.
And I was like, what?
I think that was the funniest thing about that game is that sometimes it felt like more of a mafia game where two wizards just turned the corner like, fireball.
Like you didn't hear them coming up behind you.
Especially now we're like trying to turn around.
We were trying to get rid of the evidence.
And then you and like Limo and Mitt were like, fireball.
Fireball.
Yeah, it's so good, dude.
Like, because you feel like it's so monotone, it's like execution style.
I know.
Did you guys plan that?
It kind of felt like a paintball game.
Like, that's got to feel like what it was like playing paintball.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like we got, there was a hit on us there.
I'm surprised I can't hear you guys' like footsteps.
So we didn't have a Disney suddenly.
Right.
approach yeah you guys are late least sneak attack goodbye snuffy and doki you're gonna sleep with the fishes tonight are you kidding me it might have just done doki v everybody we're live who had six kills on us oh yeah like i don't understand like it was like we have no british support i feel like there was no like american support like yeah it could not really that way like you know like a that fucking game is to have an American-British hybrid accent.
That's the key.
Yeah, like every time.
It's the most wizard tone.
Every word you say, the game registers.
And then it took Min and I's like five times to say one thing.
I liked my fireball.
I don't know why.
Yeah, I would be like fireball and it would just be like...
And I would be like fireball and then she shoots like seven fireballs at us.
Go back to Hogwarts, idiot.
Love you, son.
You got to repeat your first year.
I think I know who's the hufflepuff here.
Rip any English learners trying to play this game.
Next time I am going to practice on British English.
Aluminum.
Yes.
You're going to be out here going 40 water bottles in my aluminium.
cup oh approximately 30 degrees celsius i swear to god no thank you the warmest water it's a hot day outside i don't know i swear to god i wonder if the game would register my voice more if i put it on indian mode if i i think i think another streamer had to do that so maybe oh my like different languages and stuff?
You have like an accent.
You could change the game to like Indian English.
Oh.
Indian accent.
That's kind of cool.
I feel like I have an accent though.
Yeah.
You guys don't really like strike me as people with like, I mean, we all have different ways of speaking.
But I didn't recognize it.
Accent.
I think it was just weird because even me for Fireball, I have like people say I have a Midwestern accent.
be like america what's a midwestern accent a child would probably say so they'll be like oh yeah i can hear that from snuffy and i'll just stand there like what does that mean what does that mean what does midwestern accent wait they say oh what ah midwestern no i don't i have no idea oh oh the midwestern
I know Vinny's played Lifeline, but has Doki yet?
Doki, have you played Lifeline yet?
Oh, my God.
No.
Doki, you need to play Lifeline.
You need to play Lifeline.
Lifeline.
I was like, Lifeline from Apex?
Like, no.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've been like, you have voice from Apex Legends.
It's like, it's a voice-controlled PS2 game, and that game will make you doubt the way that you say any words ever in the English language.
It will just make you feel like you're just speaking a completely different language.
I did that with hey you Pikachu and Pikachu made me feel like I was schizophrenic like oh wait I tried to play that fish game what was it the where you raise a human fish face guy what oh yeah oh my god yeah I've seen that yeah and like it did not work I did not I for some reason I could not get the microphone to work and then I just raised all the fish and then I just let all the fishes die in the tank no yeah that was sea man I think that's like a really yeah it was seamen yeah yeah i was trying to like get them to talk to me but they like they refused to like like acknowledge me and then i was like fine i'll just starve all of you to death i'm gonna post a picture you guys might have seen this this is seamen 1999 it's a game oh i know fish people how beautiful can you talk to them yeah and he grows into a he grows into a fucking lizard Ew,
I would be so rude to him.
Not the lizard.
I mean, he's pretty ugly.
A freak.
Yeah, he is a freak.
What if that's the Depp's face?
Somebody said they poop out of their dangler.
Oh, and what?
Oh, did you see that?
What's a dangler?
Did you see, like, how they mate?
Wait, the human fish?
Oh, I think he's the only one who's actually played the game oh god here oh it's like no don't say here don't say here slide something your way it's like avatar dude are they wait wait just on the thumbnail are they doing it doggy it looks like it can i pull this up on two sea man mating here's a better version she's a better quality no sega dreamcast sea man game mating footage you're looking this is in
From Mr. J-Dog with 600 and 10 views.
I'm gonna give the link to you guys.
You can watch it.
There we go.
Yeah, I'll give the link to you guys.
Thanks, J-Dog.
It's more like a mosquito, I think.
There's two videos because Doki's really into it.
It reminds me, have you ever seen the old movie, it's called Slither?
It has like...
She linked the second video.
It has like Merle from The Walking Dead in it.
And he kind of does that, like, when he has that whole thing with the weird, like, tube thing, and it, like, for reproduction.
And you kind of just brought back a really horrible memory.
Thank you.
Wait, what?
Oh, I do know this.
Yeah, it's like, it's like Merle from the Walking Dead and Nathan Phelan.
Merle and Nathan Phelan?
Yeah.
What movie is it called?
Slither.
Yeah.
At one point, a woman blows up with...
like little slug creatures and then explodes yeah yeah in the 2006 oh it's from james gun yeah oh my god i like james gun there we go his name is michael brooker so i can start calling him gun you could be in the next slither no no thank you yeah sign me up i'll be inflated with what And I'm not,
no, I'm going to go eat my dinner.
Thanks, Snuffy.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, chat, before we decided on Mage Arena, there was another game that I brought up.
Oh, my God.
It was called, what was it?
Bogos.
Bogos Binted.
Yeah, there was a card.
Bogos Binted even.
Bogos Binted.
And I was like, and then I was like, guys, we should play Bogos Binted, guys.
And then Min was like, why don't, how about?
majorina no i don't i don't think i suggested that was my suggestion oh is it snuffy oh yeah no it's not even just bogos binted it's bogos binted with a question mark and it's oh right right right it's liars liars game liars bar with aliens but basically yeah yeah but with like four other game modes yeah oh yeah it was snuffy it was like that or the wizard game i think they have cool.
There's also this really funny game.
Okay, chat, this was the game that I first suggested before we pivoted.
It has, like, Italian brain rot memes in it, and I think and stuff.
What?
Wait, what?
Italian brain rot memes?
Yeah, you know.
Like, what?
Like, tongue, tongue, tongue, tongue, tongue, tongue, tongue.
Chimpanzee and badanini.
Where does that say that?
Galilee.
You don't know them all by name, dude.
They have their own theme songs.
No, but like where do you see it in the game?
Oh, I don't know.
I thought it was in there.
She also played it up and tried it out.
She played the tutorial.
She was ready.
Dedicated.
Yeah.
i made the game that's what if it wasn't like an impossible ask i think it would be so funny if we like made each other games to play in some sort of shitty way that would be so funny i wish i wish it was that easy i was gonna say a man made bogos binnet the developer's name was bad badger stop doxing my my alter ego from bad badger themselves yeah yep ggs guys i had a lot of fun gg very much everyone let's play four games later next time good night yeah it was fun casting spells with you it was fun yeah are you continuing to stream are you still streaming i will i will okay i'll send my my people your way then i would send it to you other guys but you're on youtube so i won't
I'm a YouTube streamer.
I'm not.
That's fair.
My endurance is very low.
You would be surprised, though.
I mean, give yourself more credit.
Working as hard as a streamer, I mean, that's like funny.
People will be like, duh, play games, but you do do a lot other than just like going live, so, you know?
That's sweet stuff.
You're right.
Maybe I'll stream Marvel Rivals later on Twitch.
Maybe you could play like a little kind of creature, you know?
Yeah.
Bye!
Bye, guys.
Bye, I'm leaving too.
Bye, bye.
Wow.
That was fun.
Sorry, sound team, for picking up the volume a little while ago.
But we figured it out in the end.
Guys, we figured it out.
That was fun.
I always love playing the sloppy sisters.
I am going to rest my voice because I was coughing a lot.
I'm not actually going to stream more.
Matt, more Marvel Revisator, because I was coughing a lot, so I'm going to rest my voice now.
But I hope you guys all had a great time watching.
It's always fun playing with them.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for us, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.